good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having a great
day hello jax how are you
it's only tuesday it's
like a slug i know but we're like this
week is going to be a slug to the end
because we're so excited for you know
the weekend and the holidays so we're
gonna have to work extra hard for it but
i'm just getting ready
to celebrate i'm getting ready to feel
like i deserve the holiday you know
that's the best no this is really just
the greatest time of year i can't even
explain to you ali and aj really said it
best they summed it up nicely it's the
greatest time of year
and it's here
i'll get my triangle up it's the
greatest time of year
and is here let me simply state it joy
to the world and everyone lift up your
hearts and filled with life
that song is so good and i only recently
rediscovered it thanks to your chaky ho
ho ho playlist which you know i haven't
listened to in a really long time and
it's really not what i thought it was
what do you think it was
a blend of like classics mixed with
classics done by new modern singers like
they had there was some very weird
things in there but in a good way like
what there was this one song you know
what i actually want to find it because
it's like a it's like by a rock band
it's like a cover like i really hope you
know what i'm talking about
if you say it i'll probably know because
that's an expertly curated playlist for
those who don't know jackie ho ho ho on
spotify is my holiday playlist that i
have been working on and contributing
towards for probably 10 years now every
year i add like the songs that i'm
listening to and then so it's a really
good amalgamation of all the best
christmas music and likes oh one of the
weirdest oh okay wait sorry one of the
weirdest i dreamed a dream by susan
boyle beautiful [ __ ] song beautiful
song gets me in the holiday spirit okay
i just need to find this one song jackie
because it really shook me i haven't
heard it probably where the [ __ ] is
susan boyle
where the [ __ ] is susan
we do need to have her on the toast all
right maybe i can't find it but i will
you know what i feel like if i look at
it oh alone this holiday by the used so
[ __ ] good see it how does it go
baby light a
candle don't say
a prayer for me yeah really random but
good so [ __ ] good i mean that's for
you know my seventh and eighth graders
on the bus listening to their ipods and
the use came out with a holiday tune for
them to listen to around that time of
year and honestly the song is so so good
if i hadn't been listening to jackie ho
ho ho while reading a book two days ago
and i heard that song i probably never
would have heard that song ever again in
my life and that's just crazy to think
about like we're living in a simulation
like they wanted me to hear that song
yeah no it's the power of jackie ho ho
ho also i finally indulged in the new
kelly clarkson christmas album i hadn't
had the time or space but i was writing
all of my holiday cards on sunday bruno
was santa's helper i'm sure you guys saw
my instagram he was elfing around
and i put on the album and it's just
just kiss the problem is though that her
original christmas album is
so [ __ ] fantastic bop after bob like
classics and like songs that she wrote
and songs that she wrote by the way that
are turning into classics right so it's
like you don't want to listen to the new
album because then you're not listening
to those songs so i did find a playlist
that was every kelly clarkson christmas
song ever including like remixes and
it's flames what do you think is the
best kelly clarkson original christmas
song
underneath the tree yeah uh here where
you should be snow is falling and the
carousing just wasn't the same it
[ __ ] pops off so hard it's going so
hard on tick tock right now
and they're actually this guy who does
like a lot of music content who i
actually really enjoy i'm just like
always learning interesting things it's
like
modern christmas songs that will
eventually end up being classics he just
started the series and the first one was
that song by kelly clarkson because the
fact that it hasn't been around forever
is shocking it's really just an instant
classic no it's so good but she has so
many great songs on that album wrapped
in red
and
that's the name of the album actually
but it's also a song and
she's just the queen the queen of
christmas sorry mariah like i know you
have i know that mariah carey is
technically the queen of christmas
because like the one song really trumps
all the others but there's a lot of
really good mariah carey christmas
covers on your playlist she does amazing
covers of classics too
that's probably
one of her best songs honestly yeah no
she really gets you in the mood for new
year's turn up and it's like a [ __ ]
banger yeah
um but wait i had something else i
wanted to tell you about music just give
me one second okay anyways head over to
spotify for the playlist i need to
update it for like the new songs this
year i haven't had a chance to listen to
carrie underwood's new album
but
i will i will get to it i remembered
what i was gonna say um
oh my god
it was about mariah oh kelly do you feel
like kelly clarkson is having this
moment right now kelly clarkson's been
having a moment yeah but like we we've
been knowing but in the world like we've
uh yes we've known since like 2001 kelly
clarkson is having a moment but the
world has been knowing for i would say
a year now like it's been a lot of
different things i think it's really
amped up because i think with like the
kelly clarkson show yes like the world
new but those were like already the
kelly fans i'm talking about like the
gen z years who's like who's kelly
clarkson i'm telling you like kelly
being on the voice and becoming friends
with ariana grande i'm on tick tock i
haven't been on the
is a moment within a moment but it's
like everybody i do feel like for the
last year six months to a year
kelly's been having like her shine okay
but can i tell you like jenzy is now
coming on to kelly and this is how i
know it's partly in thanks to ariana you
know she does kalyoke on the kelly
clarkson show like every day
yeah well so she does a cover of a
popular song every day since her show
has been she's covered i don't know if
you guys know that if you ever go to one
of her concerts she performs a different
concert a cover at every single concert
but recently all of her kalyoke covers
from the kelly clarkson show have been
coming up on my tic toc because she did
billy eilish i don't relate to you
whatever that's happier than ever and
the the kids were [ __ ] quaking on
tick tock jackie they were like shook
they said of some some people said it
was better than billy like that's what
people say and now with the seven rings
covers she just did she is like reaching
an entirely new audience and i'm telling
you like this is only the beginning of
the moment for kelly
kelly
like you go girl i'm so happy
for her i'm happy for honestly for the
kids that they're getting this level of
talent injected into their everyday life
and i'm happy for you honestly it's nice
to see your hard work pay off you know
why i'm happy for me it's that in all of
these 20 years of kelly stanhood like i
have never felt disappointed by her and
you never wavered once no not even about
me like just about her like i just i
can't recall a moment where i was ever
like
unsure
or like just felt
that i waned in my kelly stanhood yeah
she's been like a a stable force in your
life she yeah she really is like a
stable role model also she's definitely
a role model i do want to say though
we haven't gotten new music from her
that wasn't christmas music in like six
years the last album was meaning of life
and it was really good because she does
is it the piece by piece one no that was
before that but meaning of life was good
but it wasn't like my favorite ever
what's the album called before that um
with piece by piece and all those jams
dance with me
what's that album called
i'll find it and like heartbreak song
that's the best that's i think is one of
the best pop albums like every time
and like no one [ __ ] cared because
kelly was like ignored by a lot of
people for a long time
yeah
anyways i look forward to some you know
exciting new secular music from her
piece by piece is what the album's
called okay that makes sense so yeah her
entire discography page on spotify like
is christmas i'm just gonna put that out
there for 2022 that's what i'm going to
manifest a secular album from kelly yeah
i feel like i put piece by piece in the
category that i put like native by one
republic just like
underappreciated best pop album of all
time yeah too great yeah white smiling
no nothing it's like
are you gonna say that's one of the
things i always bring up it's becoming
okay that you know what i'm proud of
that like sorry i have immaculate taste
in boy bands i have no regrets
no regrets i said what i said it's a
man-band they're they'll always wonder
one republic is a man band no one
republic is just a band
it's just a man and a band yeah it's a
man and some unidentifiable men speaking
of bring back songland
yes what the [ __ ] and actually i saw
someone uh people were talking about it
on like maybe it was a choice group and
they were saying esther dean is like
involved in another show now she is
battle of the cover bands so does that
mean she's out on songland i don't think
so because i'm sure she's just doing
this in the in between because i've not
watched battle of the cover bands but i
can imagine it's nothing of the sort and
it's nothing compared to songland no
like yeah exactly it's literally the the
antithesis like of we're covering songs
as opposed to writing them we like we
can't have anything good no hopefully i
mean i haven't heard anything but you
know because we do love the show like it
will get cancelled yeah of course
because we are toxic and we curse
everything yeah everything that i've
ever loved canceled
since i was young yeah that's why you
loved me so much i got cancelled
um we've got a great show for you guys
we've got the fast five and it's tuesday
which means it's your toasters day our
advice segment will be at the end of the
show we've got a little tv recap jackie
finally caught up on succession we'll
talk about that before dear toasters yes
so much to discuss i'm really glad
something happened yeah something big i
guess like once a season in the finale
something happens and then like that
then the next season is spent like
everything plays out
not really just sort of like pussyfoots
around this big new change that like
doesn't even signify change you would
have thought like at the end of last
season when um
kendall did what he did in that press
conference that that would have upended
everything in the next season and it
kind of like didn't they just had a lot
of conversation well he just like
spoiler alert like failed
yeah but like he it just sort of petered
out yes towards the end of the season
it's like are you still against your
family i can't tell yeah he lost steam
anyways we'll recap it and that's really
exciting and i finished my horrible book
still horrible how many stars tell tell
people how many stars you gave it one
single star what was it called drag it
okay here's the thing i hate dragging a
book because someone spent time and
energy that's so writing this they put
their heart into it they put their foot
into it it was not for me on any level
it was awful it was worse than i could
have
imagined when i thought i was reading a
covid book and i in the beginning i
thought it was like kovitz in the
background which is like kind of
interesting because that's where we are
right now where i just read uh tessa
bailey's new book references the fact
that where we were in lockdown right so
i i was uh but then it just if you've
read the book you know it takes the
craziest turn i explained it to claudia
yesterday it sounds like it was written
by the person and the person in the
world who's the most out of everyone in
the world the number one person who's
most scared of kovacs yes yeah it was
like the fear mongers guide to koben
yes in a lot of ways yes and so i really
didn't like it but i needed to finish it
just to see where it was going in order
to give have an opinion and to reach my
goodreads goal and so it's a one for me
but then i was like reading all these
reviews on goodreads and like people
really loved it great loved like they
said it was the best book they read this
which is which is so
funny and you know what's actually also
really funny so there's a thread in the
redheads right now
the facebook group people sharing the
worst books they read this year is my
book and they're all crying okay but
it's like every single comment is
someone's favorite book no of course
like luckiest girl alive is there a
number of times like oh yeah the
invisible life of addy larue like all of
these books that like someone loves but
also someone hates and that's just books
yeah that's true actually you know as an
author myself of a new york times
bestselling book girl with no job the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
there's monster available anywhere you
buy books amazon kindle barnes noble
indie bookstores um
no i know that like my book either like
you're going to love or you're going to
hate and it's very personal it's so
personal
books are more personal than comedy and
food yeah and you know i'm not in the
right business for someone who's desire
is to be 100 validated because i'm in
the books business and the comedy
business yes
um i also finished a book yesterday i'm
just plowing through to my 30 goodreads
the fact that i will have read 30 books
when like up until
last year up until a year ago i probably
had read four books since i left high
school
is i'm so proud of myself like and
honestly i was talking about it
yesterday couldn't have done it without
you like you really you gave me the
kindle you gave me the resources you
gave me luckiest girl alive which really
changed my life and then you threw in
evelyn hugo which just really changed my
life i'm like this is books like who
knew yeah couldn't have done it without
you truly like 100 of the credit goes to
you i'm so proud of you and i also just
want to say in the exact same boat like
in 2020 i read 65 books this is insane
in 2019 i i read five and they were all
on vacation at the end of the year in
2018 i probably read zero books oh for
sure like
from the time i left high school the
books i probably read were the three
andy cohen books like that's it yeah
it so i'm just feeling really proud of
myself and yesterday i read the new
tessa bailey book window shopping which
i started and put down after seven
percent i'm like i can't read this and i
don't know what compelled me to keep
going but it was adorable it's perfect
for end of year reaching your goals like
i read it in literally three hours it
was so fast there was like obviously
like the fatal flaw of the book is like
this girl gets her dream job and like
her dream job is being uh a window
designer which is just really niche and
and she keeps talking about her dream
like it's like you know being a
ballerina like i just couldn't i don't
know it's reminding me of cruella it was
a little corny in a sense were you
getting cruella vibes no actually but
now that you say it maybe but i wasn't
when i was reading the book but the only
problem was that like i was picturing
the main guy are you gonna read the book
i don't know i might this book is
getting the wildest skew of reviews yeah
in the redhead's face whatever this
guy's really tall and goofy that's like
his thing and i'm telling you i could
not close my eyes without thinking that
he was tom womp's games like
the way he described his body and like
his personality i was like oh my god tom
scams from succession is this man in the
book aiden it was so weird that's really
funny tom womp scans from pride and
prejudice literally
that's crazy maybe i'll read it i just
started another book the family which is
a dana's recommendation and also it was
a read by read with jenna choice and she
always chooses really good books um who
the [ __ ] is jenna jenna bush hager from
the today show
she has a book club
and a few times our books have crossed i
think the only book we've actually both
chosen is nothing to see here is girl
with no job the crazy beautiful life of
an instagram there's monsters exactly
nothing to see here was great anytime
i've read a book that has been a jenna's
choice it's actually been really good
and i can't say that for all of the like
famous book clubs out there so um when
it has the read with jenna stamp i do i
do take it a bit seriously the read by
jbh yeah exactly very cool very cool
um now i think with further ado without
i you never know with us there might
there might be more of do about nothing
much ado
but now without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
luminess we don't have a ton of ton of
time to get ready in the morning so
we're always looking for a way to put on
makeup faster and easier makeup has
always been a challenge between not
having enough time getting a good skin
match but not anymore you gotta check
out luminess and their new breeze
cordless airbrush system it's a
completely touchless way to put on
foundation fast and easy no sponges
brushes or fingers it goes on with air
and is made for everyday application
within just minutes okay i should say
i've had my makeup done using this using
luminesce products like a couple times
in the past and the way the makeup lays
on your face is so sickening but i
thought it was something i could only
really get done with a makeup artist but
now that they have this breeze cordless
airbrush system that it's so small it's
like smaller than my phone it lays your
foundation on so gorgeous they have so
many shades you can find the perfect
match it's very cool to be able to do it
at home when i thought it was something
i was really only gonna be able to do
with um
a makeup artist super convenient it's a
handheld airbrush cordless and
rechargeable you can bring it wherever
you need it has a no mess tip that
prevents it from spraying in your hair
or your eyes it's available in 18 shades
so there's a color for every skin type
it is water-based cruelty free products
made in the usa clean and has an 18-hour
wear so there's no more heading to a
happy hour after work needing to reapply
your makeup
um whether you're updating your beauty
routine because you're heading back to
the office or you're just getting
looking for a better faster way to put
on your foundation we've got good news
right now if you go to
breezeairbrush.com
toast you'll receive 50 off the airbrush
makeup system plus free shipping and
because you're a listener there's a
special free gift included for you so
it's 50 off plus free shipping when you
go to breezeairbrush.com
toast breeze is spelled b-r-e-e-z-e
airbrush dot com slash toast don't
forget you get 30 days to experience the
airbrush in your own home and send it
back for a full refund if you don't like
it which i highly doubt
great our first story kim kardashian
says no counseling or reconciliation
effort will repair her marriage to kanye
west
kim wants to terminate her marriage to
her estranged husband kanye sooner
rather than later
kim filed documents to move forward with
her divorce and requested to be legally
single after she first filed for divorce
from the rapper in february of 2021.
in her latest filing obtained by people
on monday kim asked to have child
custody and property matters be separate
from her marital status so she is
forging ahead you know kim please come
back to me didn't stop her from filing
more specifically
kimberly these court documents which to
me i'm this is
par for the course i feel i'm not
feeling no i think you're being
delusional no why i think that they
should get divorced
and then officially get back together i
don't know i don't know if they need to
get like remarried ever but i think
they'll find their way back to each
other i think that for kim like to be
married you know in legally and also be
doing her own thing like i don't think
that's what she wants i think she wants
a fresh start i think she should have
that i just do think that this start
will lead to an end that might involve
kanye but i think that they should
continue with their divorce proceedings
oh okay i didn't realize it that way but
i definitely see what you're saying
yeah i saw this as more like so
elizabeth taylor and she loves her
kim loves elizabeth taylor yeah
okay i mean it's for me it's giving you
know greg and nene you know like fully
divorced and then had a whole other
wedding that's my frame of reference but
elizabeth taylor works too um
yeah i mean
i don't know like she's also dropping
the west
that's a sh that's a shame but i
understand it's a shame because like by
the way what is going on with kkw beauty
is it still in the rebrand yeah but also
now it's gonna have to be kkk beauty
which just doesn't sound great yeah i
would i'm like
it's crazy that she made west such a
part of her brand to begin with when she
was already a household name and so now
to have to
change all the signage is a lot of
work
so but i mean it makes sense that she's
dropping west and she doesn't need to
have it no
but i but the businesses will be
affected yeah but so maybe this like kkw
rebrand coming with her divorce filing
will get a new name just maybe kim
kardashian beauty i think that sounds
better than kk beauty yeah
whatever as it pertains to the divorce
um
i don't know if i'm really like
i'm not 100 in on them getting back
together i'm very open to the idea but i
also just love like kim like having
the opportunity to look elsewhere like
it's fun you know she's in her 40s she
looks the best she's ever looked at the
top of her game like she should be able
to enjoy the fruits of her labor yeah i
agree i'm here with and also if they
don't get back together this has been so
like tumultuous dragged out almost said
i'm very comfortable with the idea of
them not being together it would just be
like the greatest treat if they did but
i my i will be okay if they don't i
agree like we're we're past the initial
shock yeah no i feel like the way that
they did this was best for the grieving
process you know especially like there
was rumors first then there was we got
comfortable with the rumors and then
there was solidification it was a long
drawn-out thing that eventually we were
just like okay and tired of getting used
to yeah even like these news stories
like i'm just
i'm just kind of over it like let them
live yeah i'm old like just i'm here for
them getting divorced i'm also here for
kanye's you know big
romantic gestures gestures and i'm also
here for kim and pete i'm here for all
of it i'm here for all of it like i'm
i'm here for it and i'm just here for
the happiness of everyone i don't know
kim just passed the baby bar like she's
so much coming
up down the pipeline she needs to focus
you know 100 she might be joining a new
law firm could be lawyers in the mix one
of them catches her eye over late night
briefing the mckenzie file is sitting
between them it's so like legally steam
is coming off the file yeah maybe he's
like a first-year associate named emmett
and they have to drive to a remote
location to talk to a witness
and then kim gets the alibi from her
sorority sister but she can't say it
because she swore to secrecy and
professor callahan says screw sisterhood
and that's wrong just an idea just an
idea anything's possible now when you
believe that's what you need to add to
your christmas playlist
you know
my cold icy heart
as it pertains to pentatonix
was slowly melted when i heard the
pentatonix
cover of you will when you believe by
mariah carey and whitney houston
it is probably one of the most beautiful
arrangements of the song with maron
morris and it's on my playlist oh it is
okay i would listen to the playlist
almost i'm full yesterday and it didn't
come on so hmm
spotify must be a me thing i
because you're not going to call me out
like that no no no i didn't really um i
wouldn't say call out i wouldn't say
that you did no i probably would i would
phrase it like that try to embarrass the
playlist i don't think i would try to
poke holes in something i've worked so i
don't think i would phrase it like that
i just think that i was being
constructive
right right thank you because i just
want you to be the best version of
yourself while curating your playlist
you know thank you so much it's a
pleasure our next story travis scott is
out of coachella 2022 line up following
the astro world tragedy
i think that's for the best travis scott
has been effectively removed from the
lineup of performances from the 2022
coachella valley music and arts festival
variety has learned the development
follows a report in palm springs which
reported that the rapper was dropped
from the bill following the tragedy
which occurred at his own astral
festival in november was he a headliner
he was one of the headliners and sources
say the festival informed his agent of
its intent to pull travis from the bill
which he was to headline and that it
would pay a kill fee for the
cancellation typically 25
an insider adds that uh his agent had
been steadfast in trying to keep the
slot which would have marked travis's
return to the stage after
world i had heard that they offered to
do it for free
travis
offered to do it for free and they still
said no well to be honest i mean i'm not
just something i heard i'm not going to
coachella but if i was purchasing a
ticket and i saw travis like i would
definitely think twice about it i have
to imagine
people aren't comfortable it's not been
long at all i don't think i would feel
comfortable at a travis scott concert
for a while i would agree that was my
same thought because you know i'm not
sure eventually he will perform again
and if people want to buy a ticket to
his concert and big environment then
that's fine but
coachella being like a festival of so
many different artists and
people and it's just i i think it would
also just they don't i'm sure they want
nothing to do with that tragedy yeah and
i think that that event really cast a
light on like maybe some security issues
at other festivals and i'm sure now
moving forward other festivals are gonna
have like way more precautions in terms
of like guard rails and just like a
million things i think it was like a
terrible thing that nobody else wants to
experience at their festivals so
i i can't imagine any festival even
remotely wanting to be associated with
this man right especially to be the
first one back right
okay in 10 years maybe but like yeah but
not like i'm sure they just want their
festival to go off they've already been
through like so much with all the
postponements and cancellations and
i think this is the right decision who's
going to fill in i don't know
we shall see
excuse me you know it would be great but
like maybe a little early for her olivia
rodrigo like because when this lineup
was announced she wasn't really at the
place that she's at now her entire tour
sold out she played like austin city
limits she played rolling loud
i think that would be headline those no
it's like during the daytime but still
like i think the coachella crowd the
thing with olivia rodrigo is like she's
so new but she's so much more famous
than people who have been around for 10
years like i think she actually like
could could headline i know that's crazy
i think she like
it would be it would
it would be really crazy yeah i know it
would be
but like billy
well first remember when we went billy
eilish was at a different stage she was
super new in like the third
row yeah
and and now she's like headliner stats
oh yeah but i think it might be like
still a little that's true billy eilish
is a good comparison yeah
our next story little justice news larry
nassar survivors to receive an
additional 380 million dollar settlement
after a year's long lawsuit battle
fabulous from who usa usa gymnastics and
the u.s olympic and paralympic committee
have agreed to a settlement with the
survivors of sexual assault of larry
nassar who filed lawsuits against the
former osteopath that's really not
enough money
according to the usag's official site a
federal bankruptcy court in indianapolis
on monday confirmed a 380 million
settlement between and those who were
assaulted by nassar during his two
decade tenure with usag overseeing the
medical treatment of gymnasts hoping to
represent team usa in the olympics usag
and us opc will also provide several
other non-monetary provisions to the
lawsuit complaints including a dedicated
seat on usag's board of directors and an
investigation into the organization's
culture and practices oh great so if
some of the survivors are like involved
in usa gymnastics now i can just put
them on the board put them on the board
like that makes this much less likely to
ever happen again yeah but if it's going
to be survivors on the board not just
like hey we're going to have a board
seat of someone who's like making sure
this doesn't happen again oh sorry i i
mis i interpreted it it as someone
one of the survivors it just says a
dedicated seat you know it could be
someone who's like some [ __ ] yeah
yeah
okay well it's a start love the 380
million for the girls
um
i just literally load this man with
every fiber of my being
and i hope he's having a miserable life
in front of him yes i agree in a prison
we do love to see a little justice we do
love to see a little justice and those
girls are so brave like after all
they've been through they're just heroes
they're role models they really are they
really really are um
before you continue do you mind if i
just say a little something please do
do do
do do you've got to check out omaze the
new way to enter to give back to charity
and have fun doing it here's how omaze
works you enter for the chance to win
something amazing and at the same time
you can donate to support great causes
it's fun and easy it's a fun and easy
way for non-profits to raise money and
for you to win big prizes like a
multi-million dollar house in miami
here's how it works go to
omaze.com toast that's omaze.com
toast select the miami dream house or a
different experience of your choosing
and then once you've selected your prize
you can choose a donation amount from 10
to 150
the more you donate the more entries you
get through your donations omaze has
raised more than 150 million dollars to
support over 350 non-profits around the
world
everyone deserves a chance to live their
dreams and with oma's extraordinary
prizes are within reach for everyone
enter today for your chance to win the
miami dreamhouse or other life-changing
prizes and experiences at omaze.com
toast plus receive 20 extra entries when
you enter code toast 20. that's
omaze.com
toast and use code toast 20 toast 2-0 to
receive 20 extra entries
great
our next story speaking of olivia
rodrigo she's belting out her hit song
driver's license at the real life dmv oh
i saw her um tiny desk ooh wow really
disrespected the book and it's atrocious
i'm so sorry yes i saw she did her tiny
desk concert at the dmv which was very
cute uh yeah most americans dread a trip
to the dmv but olivia rodrigo was
willing to hang out at one of the
offices after hours the singing
sensation spent time at the glendale dmv
in california earlier this month
recording a show of npr's tiny desk
concert series the unusual gig location
was a reference to her big hit driver's
license which she performed at the dmv
along with three of her other hits her
team reportedly paid two thousand three
hundred and eighty three dollars to use
the dmv office after it closed to the
public for the day economical yeah i
mean it's a little on the nose but i
mean i just like the dmv
will never be an aesthetic i know
everybody hates the dmv but i feel like
i hate it more than that you don't even
have a license i know but that's but i
think it's because of like just the dmv
trauma that i've experienced okay
they're just so mean
and they just like
there's oh my god especially in new york
because you get like new york attitude
plus dmv attitude and it's just it's in
my first permit photo like i literally
have tears in my eyes
because they're like yelling at me like
to go do and this and that i'm just like
i'm just a kid yeah no that's the thing
when you when you first experience the
dmv and i think why we're all so
emotionally scarred by it because when
you're like 15 16 17 getting your permit
and you're so young and impressionable
and they're so mean to you always that's
why i think as a society we all have
like childhood trauma from the dmv and
like you're so excited to be doing this
thing it's such a big deal they just
rip you to shreds they just take a dump
on it yeah i'm actually dreading the day
that i have to go in for a new photo
because i have the same photo i've had
my my license expire i think maybe once
since i've gotten it but they just send
me a new one with the same photo but i
do think eventually i'll have to take a
new photo right yeah probably i can't
tell you how little i'm looking forward
to it because my photo right now is
hella cute oh look at you yeah like it's
just like a random thing like i actually
looked like pretty that day yeah but
it's always interesting like those
pictures like whether it's licensed
pictures passport whatever like they
really are a sign
of yeah you can't face tune you can't do
a little trust me i've tried turn of the
head like that's your big face no ring
light that's your face and you're stuck
with it yeah and like a lot of the times
you have to put your hair behind your
ears something about like showing your
ears in your picture and that's just
like the most unflattering i don't mind
it i actually did something crazy last
time i had a photo taken i didn't update
like i didn't do an updo i just had my
hair like what photo was this for like
passport yeah one of those
and it was very brave yeah no but it
turned out like kind of cute okay well
just like pro tip i haven't had my photo
taken like my passport and my
license are like on the verge of
expiring so i haven't taken a photo in
like eight years you can't ride like 40
pounds you know yeah yeah i actually
have to practice like no and like do
some you know ice rolling yeah yeah gua
sha yeah really get the face as tight
and trimmed right into that show up to
dmb looking and feeling your best yeah
but like after all the
[ __ ] they put you through you're like
sweating you're crying after being made
to feel like you're worse yeah yeah you
gotta bring the ice roller with you no
wonder i never went back yeah but olivia
rodrigo is
throwing herself into the lines it was a
very good cause she has good
associations with the dmv because it's
where she did get her driver's license
which like
you know changed her life opened up the
whole world to her literally
figuratively musically so i would
imagine like she looks at it fondly yeah
i wonder if she's going to continue
doing
at smsm she is
yeah she said when they go back to
filming i saw that she said that that
that she's in i have to imagine she's
like
feels like brought down by it a little
bit like she's just on this trajectory
and this
thing that yes of course did contribute
to her but like she's outgrown and she
definitely has well i think i mean
perhaps she has but i think she has all
these new fans now who are going to want
to watch her on it and i think she's
going to make it an even bigger show and
now she has like this acting thing going
on where she also gets to sing and she
this music that they write for her or
that she writes is very really good and
i think it just adds to her portfolio
yeah but i do think like a lot of her
new fans like some of the older ones
like we can't watch it like i watch the
first season it was like super cute
especially given like the whole story
with joshua the second season like it's
really for for children like it's it's
like embarrassing to watch it because i
was going to say i liked the first scene
so did i but i just realized i never
watched the second season it was like i
felt embarrassed like to be watching it
like ben came in he's like why are you
watching like i can't tell you
damn it's for kids okay but maybe the
third season like that now they know
they have this new audience but i think
that they can if they made it more of
like a little bit of a mature show
like a degrassi
i think it could be good i think that
they could and probably will do but i
think they realize there's an
opportunity here and it's also disney
plus like they have right it's not on
disney channel like they can get a
little they could throw in a [ __ ] you
know yeah no but also they can hire the
right people to make sure that it's like
a good show is this a kenny ortega
production high school musical the
musical the series i think so it doesn't
have the candy or take a stamp on it no
it doesn't have the kenny ortega like
there's not a jazz square in sight no
and that's how you know that's how you
know
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
it's the final story
it's the final story
i can't think of anything to say
and that's a magic number
okay what is it hit me with it i'm gonna
hit you with it it's a little clarity
around some of our conversation from
yesterday about the peloton commercial
oh i have one thing i want to say okay
before we dive in
before we dive in something totally
unrelated i have to issue a correction
yesterday when i was talking about the
sex lives of college girls i said renee
rapp was a lesbian because that's what i
saw on tick tock she's not she's a
boyfriend so sorry i did not mean to
like miss
okay identify anyone got it completely
unrelated no but just you reminded me of
yesterday yesterday's tings well we were
also talking about when did this peloton
uh commercial come together why is ryan
reynolds always like doing peloton stuff
here's the thing first of all it did
come together in the last 48 hours post
premiere of just like that i just want
to say like yes that's what
everyone who's involved in the
commercial like
peloton social media ryan reynolds all
the actors that's what people are saying
i did have someone in my dms who works
like high up at a production company say
that like these contracts were going out
like chris nothing stuff in june that's
all i want to say i saw that you got a
dm i sent it to you you sent it to me
and then i also got a dm from that
person who's really adamant that this
was happening back during the summer so
just want to say i also got a dm from
someone who works at peloton who said
this happened in the last 48 hours okay
so and the you know
the public line is that it did happen in
the last 48 hours ryan reynolds is
production company maximum effort was
the driving force behind the commercial
which is why he did the voiceover which
is why he did the voiceover now i don't
know if this has anything to do with his
parody of the christmas commercial from
a few years ago or if that's just
totally
a coincidence but it does feel like he's
always you know injecting himself in the
middle of peloton tings
so pilatings
48 hours good for them if it's if true
big if true well what i said yesterday
is like it wasn't a very highly produced
commercial like it was one scene it
wasn't like a
a story like there was literally just
one camera
two people a couch one set it could have
been
sliced together and edited in 48 hours i
do think that's still possible i stand
by what i said yesterday yes but it's
not that so much because that's a day's
worth of work but it's the getting like
first of all it's the
how much are we paying chris no no
negotiating seeing the episode like
realizing that oh my gosh okay we have
like a bit of a pr opportunity on our
hands it's coming up with the idea which
you know in these corporate
bureaucracies take forever to get off
the ground then we have to talk to chris
noth's agent they probably have to get
like sex in the city or max like because
they did reference it a little bit and
so i
it's the back end of that that is
surprising that got done yeah
i'm
hella skeptical
like it's possible but i am skeptical
it's funny yesterday before they
announced that it was you know 48-hour
turnaround you were more believing that
it was 48 hours but now they like want
us to believe it so bad i'm not
believing it
wow
they think that they know that i know
but i know that they know that i know
wow yeah she turned it around i did i
flipped the script she flipped the
script those were the past five feel as
though you needed to know them for sure
yeah but we're not even close to being
done with today's episode because we've
got so much good stuff we're gonna dive
into the tv recap which is brought to
you by hush leggetts let's talk about
the quality of your sleep jackie the
reality is over 160 million americans
struggle with sleep and hush is here to
help hush is an industry-leading sleep
brand that carries a wide range of sleep
essentials for every sleeper whether
you're hot sleeper cold sleeper they
have everything you need to get the job
done they carry everything from pillows
and sheets to their best selling
weighted blankets and mattresses they
even have their ice technology which
keeps you cool all night long with their
iced weighted blanket and their
mattresses so if you're looking to
improve your nightly rests naturally
hush is the answer
they also offer a hundred night
guarantee on all of their products so if
you can try out any of their products
for a hundred nights and return it with
no hassle whatsoever great gift for
someone in your life weighted blankets
are great for someone who's like
struggling with anxiety great gifts for
yourself also like if you just need a
refresh of your bed if you sweat sweat
in your sleep it's nice to purchase
products that are completely targeted
towards keeping you cool that's their
ice collection it's a true game changer
they also love to give back at hush from
day one they've donated one in ten adult
products and one in five kids products
to those in need around the world so if
you're looking to upgrade your sleep
head over to hushblankets.com they're
having a huge sale right now so make
sure to check it out before the sale
ends again that's hushblankets.com to
take advantage of the big sale that's
currently going on
wonderful okay succession spoiler zone
fast forward if you haven't watched yet
but season three finale popped off i
mean it was really like i was watching
it very excited because you said a lot
happens
and i was like still took me you know
two hours to get through it because
nothing was happening but then of course
the last two minutes
um we got the answers it was also a
gorgeous episode like taking place all
over aesthetically alexander skarsgard
house in what is that like like homo i
don't know i don't know where it's
supposed to be but it's so sickening
like it's just upsetting to watch like
when they go from the helicopter to the
boat to the house yeah
um honestly i was honestly thinking like
i need a zofran because
that's a lot of travel a lot of like and
also like
i've never been in a helicopter you have
though never no i'll never go on a
helicopter yeah but i think that you
like if you feel everything because it's
like not that big well i think the ones
that they're on are like the limousines
of helicopters like really fancy i don't
think it's that bad but no it's not a
mode of transportation i'm even remotely
interested in ever pursuing yeah and
then to get into a boat like i was just
like ooh where is the c band yeah like
why did everyone want to go from the
wedding like i would rather stay put at
the wedding
i just feel like this this episode
really highlighted like how [ __ ]
annoying all the kids are and i know
that like i think that most people are
like team kids which is so crazy these
kids are such [ __ ] ingrates first of
all except from kendall who's a murderer
so like it doesn't even matter neither
of them have ever even properly worked
at the company like for real like he had
a stint in la roman and then he like
quit because they didn't like his movie
or whatever and he was doing a bad job
shiv worked in politics up until a year
ago like but you expect this fortune 500
billion dollar company just to be placed
up your ass because you're logan's kids
like they're such [ __ ] ingrates and
they just expect so much from logan and
not only does logan give them nothing
which like yes i guess is frustrating as
like a kid but like you don't [ __ ]
deserve it no but i don't feel like he
gives them nothing he gives them
everything they have like billions of
dollars they don't care about that they
want the power like they do not care
about the money but what will they do
with their the power they're so
ill-equipped and also like the
entitlement yes of course like you would
hope that you know you will succeed when
the day comes but like logan has said
over and over again the day is not here
yet so like every time they don't get
what they want they're going to like go
and tell them when they feel crazy and
like deranged and like old senile man no
they're so out of control so ungrateful
and so ill-equipped to take over this
company unworthy i completely agree i
mean anyone who's team kids i can't
delusion you whatsoever like and when
logan was like making your own
aisle i would like that's it that's the
whole thing and also not only make your
own [ __ ] pile but you have a whole
pile to start with right like you have
literally every opportunity in the world
but the only thing you want is to take
away the thing your dad built [ __ ] all
no and it's like they have no respect
for the thing that that he built they
like talk so much trash about it like
they don't even like the company they
don't even like the company they don't
like their audience they don't like
anything about it so why are they so
desperate to get it i i don't know
they're such in they're so entitled well
that car ride where they're like talking
on the way
to the villa that logan's at like three
the blind leading the blind they really
thought that they were gonna storm the
bastille stage this q and like i to have
their asses handed to them in such a way
was so beautiful my only if i'm a little
rdh it's like i i do wish that roman
would have
turned because he's been like the most
loyal up until this point but it's like
i understand why he didn't like logan
once told kendall like this will be
yours just trust me and then he you know
didn't give it to him he said the same
thing to shiv and then shiv shot the bed
and i'm sorry so why should women
believe that so like when he's saying to
roman no roman like it's you know you'll
be
tops he's like listen fool me thrice
shame on me who is your least favorite
kid say it on the count of three okay
so easy you changed recently me too one
two three
okay wait who's your favorite kid one
two three
oh connor i forgot about him i love
coffee he's harmless like really yeah um
and when he had that like that whole
when kendall was like i'm the eldest son
i was like well because they have
different moms right connor has a
different mom than everyone else got it
got it so
that i i felt like he had earned his
right for a little bit of break of a
breakdown but like it's funny how nobody
cared like i know but he did earn who's
right they're so [ __ ] mean to him
there's so many team and he's the only
one who's like grateful like i can ha
my dad gave me everything in the world
i'm gonna buy a ranch marry this girl
like pretend to run for president like
he's the only one who's without his hand
so far up logan's ass yeah
yeah you're right there's value and it's
like he asks for big favors he doesn't
get them and then he doesn't go turn
around and burn down the whole thing
right he doesn't like betray his whole
family he just goes back to his million
dollar round he comes up with a new plan
but he's a bit of like a fool like he's
really job yes um
from arrested development but he's just
the only one with any sense of like
love
love exactly which is just so crazy and
then let's talk about the tom of it all
i just wasn't my least favorite
character
for i know
two seasons and eight episodes yeah
when shiv was like who the [ __ ] told him
we were coming i wasn't expecting us to
find out i just figured there's like you
know snakes everywhere like
and then it it didn't even hit me at
first he put his arm on tom and then
shiv's face is like it was just really
brilliantly done
and i loved every second of it first of
all shiv does not deserve tom thomas tom
wanted to be so loyal and like she
wouldn't let him and she's so mean to
him like [ __ ] shiv i'm so team tom i
would have done the exact same thing
yeah no i mean it's it i don't know how
they stay married after this
but how were they staying married before
like she literally treated him so poorly
and
he he was looking out for number one and
end number two cousin greg cousin greg
who's so cute and i really hope he ends
up with a princess and also like cousin
greg is pretty loyal because even when
the family was at odds like he stayed at
good with kendall and with everyone else
so
he's a good one to have on your side
right and i just i hope that you know
this
this l this big fat l for the kids like
continues on me too season after scene
because i don't know what the end goal
of the show is but if it's like the kids
winning like i'm not interested well i
think the end goal of the show is like
succession who will succeed how does you
know when
when logan because eventually he will
die either die or retire
then like what comes next
i'm here for the gojo deal by the way
like we've got to evolve yeah we've
gotta i agree and alexander skarsgard
was spitting facts she was giving like
elon musk vibes yeah i hope he was
telling that story of like mark
zuckerberg told him about like the roman
slaves and logan was like oh zuckerberg
has some kid reading history for him now
so funny
you have to watch a show with subtitles
like or you will miss out on like some
really good [ __ ] yes but i watched a lot
of the show when i was like binging and
i watched so much with subtitles and you
realize a lot of the script is because i
guess they want it to be like very
realistic a lot of it is uh
and stuttering and like kind of
repeating themselves because it's not
like yeah because it's like real
conversation and it made me really hate
the dialogue it doesn't bother me at all
oh and really having the subtitles on i
try really hard to do it without
otherwise seeing all these uh and like
small things that they say in between it
just really bothers me oh i mean i know
i noticed the errors but it doesn't
bother me and i feel like i would miss
out on half the show like i would have
no idea what's going on if i didn't
watch with subtitles yeah if i hear
something that sounds important and i
didn't get it maybe i'll go back put on
subtitles and depending it depends on
who the character is like sometimes on
yellowstone i have to put on subtitles
for um john dutton because he just
speaks so low what i thought was really
great about the episode was like they
had that conversation
greg and um tom at the wedding i had no
idea what the [ __ ] they were talking
about like and it said it was like a
weird tom thing like i didn't think
anything of it and then when he ended up
being the one who like ratted it was
just really like a full circle i'm like
oh that's why he had the conversation
with greg it was just really kind of
excellently done yeah it really
it was i just
i feel so justified i've been team logan
the whole time
and i know most people have been like
team kendall
and or even like team shiv and whatever
and just like i feel seen no i can't
believe people out there are not team
logan like that's insane to me i feel
like that's like if i meet someone i
have to ask them if their team log into
kendall because like if you're kinda
like we just have totally different
values like i completely agree like
respect your elders like
don't be ungrateful
don't be entitled like i just can't yeah
no be grateful for what you have and
like stop trying to kill your father put
him in an early grave so that you can
take over with your mediocre ideas no
and so i think a lot of people take team
kendall because they think he's like
this like progressive like hero he's
gonna like change the politics of atn
when it's like he's a bigger fraud than
the rest of that he stands for nothing
yeah not a thing right [ __ ] the page
like such a loser such a loser such a
loser
um
when he was like
yeah we've got vanity fair like during
the big interview and comrades like it's
mostly us reaching out to them like you
know it got really sad
kendall really realized at the end of
last episode when he was in the pool
that he was attempting to kill himself
well when i saw that i was like did he
just uh i didn't think anything of it i
thought it was just like an artistic
thing no i saw that and i was like uh is
kendall dead and then the previews for
next week had kendall in them so i was
like oh okay so he just took a nap right
no but i guess was in between the two
yeah
um
so yeah really good i'm surprised
there's not one more episode i just find
that extremely confusing but i guess
we'll have to wait and see
yeah but you know what if we never got
another episode i would be completely
fine with it because i'm sure in the
next season like you know logan will
have to take some l's and they'll tussle
back and forth uh and i don't want to
see that like this is the ending if the
show ended like this
beautiful beaut i actually couldn't
agree more
um okay any other tv watching you want
to recap i started the show called some
20-somethings austin which is like a new
reality show on netflix and i have to
say it's
so atrocious like it sounds good no it
sounds good and i was watching it and i
was like this kind of sucks and i posted
on my instagram and everyone was like
literally there's not one ounce of drama
like nothing happens so i just gave up
while but i thought it was interesting
that they cast like a really like normal
looking group of people like on reality
shows they're always just putting people
like i've never seen a girl like that
when i walk out on the street it was
like normal people with like normal
bodies and different like diverse
sexualities and ethnicities and i liked
that but it just wasn't good like that's
well it sounds like a good premise it
doesn't get it together and i think
they'll probably do 20 somethings like
new york not if no one's watching yeah
but you know yeah not a bad idea for a
franchise no um okay well the show is
not done yet because it is tuesday and
that means we're doing dear toasters our
advice segment so if you ever want to
write into your toasters the email is
dear toasters gmail.com we will answer
your submission anonymously um
and today's episode is brought to you by
skylight frames a photo frame that you
can update instantly by email from
anywhere it's a great way to feel close
to those you love even when you're
separated it sets up effortlessly in
under 60 seconds just plug it in use the
touch screen to connect to your wi-fi
and enjoy
sending the photos from your phone to
the skylight frame is also effortless
everyone in the family can just email
them to the personal skylight email
address and they'll pop up in seconds so
it's really tech friendly like if you're
giving this to a grandma or a mom who's
not
super techy you can set it up for them
in less than 60 seconds and they can set
it up for themselves it's super easy and
then they never have to worry about
updating the photos you do it all from
your phone emailing pictures to the
frame and they'll literally think you're
steve jobs yeah literally like that you
invented this like crazy ass like
magical frame it's really a great way to
keep in touch with people friends family
who live in different parts of the
country um they have a so it's a 10 inch
screen it's really gorgeous and you can
swipe through using your finger um and
you could also tap it to say thank you
to the person who sent it so it's just
really cute great way to stay in touch
great gift for the holidays and they
have 100 satisfaction guarantee so if
you don't love your skylight they'll
offer you a full refund
now as a special offer you can get 10
off your purchase of a skylight frame
when you go to
skylightframe.com and enter code toast
so that's 10 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go
skylightframe.com
enter code toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e
dot com promo code toast
okay you ready for your toasters i'm
ready
good morning jackie and claudia first
things first i've been a toaster for
about eight months because my friend
from college made me watch claudia's
stand-up show while i crashed her house
in minneapolis for a work trip tmt has
reinvigorated our friendship in the best
way possible we're in different life
stages right now and between life and
the geographic graphical distance we
didn't chat that often but now we talk
and joke daily about the toast and it
feels like we're in college again oh
that's very sweet
i'm currently 24 weeks pregnant with our
first child and my husband and i are so
totally at a loss for boy names he
desperately wants a little girl we don't
know the gender and for that reason
along with the fact that i come from a
four daughter family i think we're
probably having a boy we've had the girl
name picked out since day one and we are
in love with it it's a classic name and
it relates to both of our families but
as for the boy names none of them are
speaking to either of us we obviously
have times we agreed just not to think
about it for a while my husband has this
amazing friend slash mentor who's an
eccentric older man who has never been
married has no kids nieces or nephews
he's a very normal name for a man but
it's also kind of blah he's always been
so generous to us housewarming gifts
that cost thousands of dollars surprise
airplane tickets nice dinners we just
recently found out that he's worth an
obscene amount of money do i suggest to
my husband that we named the potential
boy baby after him on the absolute off
chance that our child gets set up for
life i'm so embarrassed even typing it
out but like claudia said money talks i
can't tell if he would be annoyed that i
suggested using his friend or if he
would vehemently agree and then we are
stuck with a boy with a blonde name but
a potential trust fund so here are the
questions do i keep this to myself or
tell my husband would you name the boy
after him or hold out for one that
speaks to you sincerely a toaster who
wants a daddy war box
well you should definitely talk to your
husband about it if it's on your mind
and it's an idea and like see what he
says maybe read the room maybe he would
say no i actually never even liked him i
don't want like our kids to be named
after him maybe he would like to be
touched maybe he would be like yeah oh
my god actually i think that you know we
might get the fortune and if you like
the name and there's not another name
that you love like this is a real option
so talk to him about it i'm not saying
do it but also i just want to say
there's a way for you to like get his
fortune it feels weird to say there's a
way for you to get his fortune without
naming your child like but when you do
have a child like make it clear that
this man is a very important figure
maybe make him the godfather
yeah like invite him like you can work
on getting your fortune without naming
the child so if you hate the name like
that's
you know a validity
she said it's blah she said it's a
classic male name which sometimes is
like no that's what they said about the
female name it's like a no perfectly
classic she literally said it says
has family history for both of them his
name is a classic male name that's what
he said
the girl's name we are in love with it's
a classic name and it relates to both of
our families okay and boy names none of
them are speaking to us um he has a
mentor who has a what name
he has a very normal name for a man but
it's kind of blah
that's what she said okay so it's not
i'm imagining like a matthew you know
john biblical john yeah yeah which is
like [ __ ] i mean
but also i mean i
like this is how i felt before we found
out the gender i was like i had a
million girl names picked out and not
one boy name and we needed to find out
the gender because otherwise i would
have never like spent my time on boy
names so obviously you've already made
this decision not to find out but maybe
you should just find out because oh yeah
like you just you need time to plan and
think about these things that's true
because if you find out the gender and
it's a girl you don't even have to think
about this law name yeah but they've
clearly decided not to find out the
gender but i think if you're really like
at a loss for names on one gender
you should find out yeah it might just
take some of the stress off i can't
imagine like going in kind of
unprepared like that for half of the
possibility so definitely talk about um
this idea with your husband you know
take its temperature but also you know
get some baby name books those are
always like really fun to do it is you
know it's also a great way to um find
good different names is by reading books
like that's what i was going to say i
you know last the book i read last night
the girl's name was stella and i love
that name but my best friend anna just
named her kid stella so i would never
but it was like got me thinking like
that's a gorgeous name yeah no
reading especially reading like
historical books historical fiction like
names
it's a great way to find names yeah and
the the man's name was ayden i also
thought that was a gorgeous name too
gorgeous gorgeous girls so i actually
everybody's saying that
oh okay i'm so glad you asked this is
the soup one it's from tick tock
gorgeous gorgeous girls love soup soup
girls are the most popular girls in the
chicken soup that you once sent me yeah
and then every now and then that sound
went viral and then now people are
making their own sounds like i made one
gorgeous gorgeous girls love rice
rice girls are the nicest girls in high
school like you just make up your own
little thing got it okay like gorgeous
gorgeous girls are always running late
so it's exactly what i thought it was
yeah okay cool you're just like so smart
and it started with soup yes and the
chicken coop
okay
um so yes i think we've given actually
good advice talk to your husband maybe
find out the gender really invest in
good books those are three really good
options in my opinion
but good luck with daddy warbucks even
beyond all this naming things please
keep this man close to you like give him
an important role at the christening or
something like
there's money on the table here okay
maybe you can name him after daddy
warbucks himself
yeah you know what daddy warbucks name
is
carl oliver
i love the name oliver a beautiful name
i love that name it is way too close to
olivia i know
um okay next up hi jackie and claudia
how you doing doing good huge toaster
thank you for getting me through the
pandemic so i'm getting married to my
pgm fiance cup this coming summer we've
been married first we've been together
for seven years and are from the same
hometown i've been super close with his
family and i love my future in-laws
especially his mom unfortunately
last november my fiance's maternal
grandmother passed away at the age of
99. it was definitely coming and she's
in a better place i loved his grandma
and she even gave my fiance her wedding
ring to use as my wedding band here's
where it gets awkward due to kovid we
have not had a funeral for grandma some
of the family lives in another state so
it's been difficult to coordinate a time
that works for everyone my future
mother-in-law asked my fiance if we
could have grandma's funeral the day
after the wedding my fiance is a people
pleaser and didn't give her a yes or no
we had planned on staying at our hotel
an extra night since we are going on our
honeymoon at a later date the funeral
would be two hours away and i definitely
didn't want to be hungover i feel like a
bridezilla for saying this but having
this funeral during our wedding weekend
will make the fact that the wedding is
over so much sadder am i the worst
person in the world for not wanting to
go to a funeral on my wedding weekend
what should i do love a toaster and the
least favorite daughter-in-law that's
[ __ ] insane yeah i just want to say i
think you're like in this tunnel i'm so
glad you wrote into us because you can't
see out of like this as normal people
your in-laws requesting that their
grandmother's 99th funeral be the day
after your wedding is so astonishing she
passed away a year ago
find another day [ __ ] off you have to
stand firm that will ruin your wedding
vibe it's not like the funeral is next
door so it's like everyone's in town so
let's just go over next door and then
we'll bury gran but it's like two hours
away so we all have to travel anyway i
think that's so crazy also gran should
be laid to rest before your wedding yep
that you know it's like the bad news and
then the good news you could literally
have a funeral
any day of the week it doesn't matter
like you don't it doesn't have to be
like a set like a wedding is like a
saturday night and friday night a
funeral you could have on a tuesday
morning like yeah there's literally no
reason that it needs to be the day after
your wedding this is hella disrespectful
so crazy it's like a two-for-one
wedding funeral special it's just
respectful to grant too and
you put your foot down tell your husband
it's bonkers yeah and they absolutely
like do not move you're immovable on
this issue no have the funeral next
month
have the funeral literally any time no
but like have the funeral like asap
what are we waiting for
this is asinine your mother-in-law's a
piece of work i just want to say that's
un unreasonable to ask perhaps the way
that they see it is like listen
everyone's coming to town we'll kill i
don't care one stone no but i don't know
i i just don't think a a funeral is a
bird that uses i'm assuming you're a
coveted bride like after all you've been
through seriously like [ __ ] off also if
they do want to have it like at the same
weekend as yours then at least the
funeral should be first
no like it shouldn't be on this weekend
on the at the dirty [ __ ] lease i get
it but like no no to this whole thing i
agree no to the whole thing
good luck let us know
all right finally hello claudius what
does that mean to not have a funeral for
that long like where's gran i think like
in a drawer you know
oh cremated
no in like a mortuary drawer for months
yeah it's like cold in there
no no i'm sure like but don't they have
like you can't just take up a drawer
forever
or i guess you're cremated but you don't
have a funeral for creamy you do no you
don't
because it's just a service a
celebration of life well that's not a
funeral
people who are cremated like then like
they take their ashes and like do
yeah like a funeral is a casket
okay
that's really like a lot to think about
no i know i really don't like thinking
about like physical bodies after death
we've gotta move on i can't think about
it oh no now i'm gonna sneeze i've been
triggered hold on that way that way that
way to the left
to the left to the left okay
final one hello jackie and claudia 2021
has literally been the hardest year of
my life and it would take a 100 page
essay to explain all the reasons why but
trust me when i say it's been a year i
became a toaster this year and when
y'all have
and y'all have truly kept me sane and
been a happy distraction for me through
some of the tough times thank you
so the cherry on top of my very
difficult year is that my husband and i
i'm 25 he's 26 decided to get a divorce
we've been together for six years eloped
at the end of june and we've been
talking about marriage for a long time
and i've always known that he's the one
the decision to divorce was not because
of any crazy dramatic reasons like
cheating or a big fight it was a lot of
small things we've been dealing with for
a very long time that have been piling
up and we've been sweeping under the rug
we both love each other so much but we
reached a point where we needed where we
realized we may not be each other's end
game needless to say it's very [ __ ]
hard however i'm not running in for
advice about my relationship or how to
handle the end of it although i do
welcome any kind words i'm writing in
because we were only married for about
five months and i'm really embarrassed
even though everyone around me is
telling me not to be ashamed or
embarrassed i can't help it this is the
person i truly imagine spending the rest
of my life with having children with etc
and we've talked about that for the last
six years with my friends and family now
suddenly i'm like a divorcee at 25 years
old after a five-month marriage like
what the [ __ ]
literally just typing that sentence made
me cringe i feel like people think that
i was impulsive when i married him and
that we couldn't just handle the married
life and called to quits after five
months i know that it is so much more
later than that and i know the truth but
i feel like everyone around me is
judging me i'm trying to survive the
heartbreak of it all but now i feel like
i have to explain myself to people too
what the [ __ ] do i do and how the [ __ ]
do i handle this love you all so much
and thanks for any advice claudia i'm in
austin and we'll be attending end log
and i can't wait to see you p.s if this
actually makes it on a youtube episode
please tell the toasters watching on
youtube to comment their advice on how
to get through a long-term relationship
breakup i need all the advice i can get
right now thanks okay so you hear that
if you're listening and you have advice
on long-term relationship breakup drop a
comment on youtube because the girl who
wrote in will be reading them yes okay
so
my advice is less so on long-term
relationship breakup because that's just
like you know the grieving process so
she wants our advice like how to handle
like the stigma the stigma the optics
and first of all like
you have you're unwavered in your
decision and you know that it was the
right thing to do and that's the most
important thing like there's no regrets
you know what you did was right and even
though and i feel like this is such a
corny
motto but i was seeing it going around
like in 20 20 22 on we stopped caring
about what things look like and start
caring about what things feel like so
yes like maybe it looked like the a
great relationship and it was six years
and you guys were just like taking each
next step but like who cares what what
it looks like when it feels like [ __ ]
that's true and i think that
obviously it's easier to like you know
easier said than done but like you have
to put people's opinions out of your
head like they don't know what it was
like you made the best decision for
yourself and like you have saved
yourself so much time
energy and if there are people around
you who are like speaking negatively
they're doing you a favor by showing you
their true colors like those aren't
people friends or family that you should
really be like hanging out with if they
can't even just be by your side and like
and and defend you
when you're going through a tough time
no and like to get to be together for
six years to get married and then get
divorced months later like really
something isn't right and so yes you
could have like
in their view you could have trucked on
and then like but then the problems
become bigger and then there's more time
wasted and like what you're 25 years old
right your whole life isn't ahead of you
you
you've got to change your perspective
because you just did the best thing for
yourself you've liberated yourself
and go like enjoy i mean obviously it's
a little soon but like hit the town i
just want to say alternative um
like idea
i think there's something like
incredibly cool and chic about being
divorced at 25 i just want to say like
barry evelyn hugo it's very just like oh
you're so cosmopolitan you've been
through so much you're so mature i don't
really think like if i don't know anyone
who's 25 and divorced but if i did i
would oh i'm sorry like taylor schrecker
is one of the most interesting people i
know and she got divorced at like 28 i
think like i would be
she's so interesting like i would love
to i think it makes you an interesting
person i just want to say i maybe not
everyone thinks that but if i met
someone who's 25 and divorced i'd be
like tell me your whole life right far
more interesting than someone who's
staying in a marriage that's really not
making either of them happy 100 and
you're far braver
and
you'll be so much better in the in the
long run yes you made this decision like
i know you know you made the right
decision so we don't have to tell you
that but it will make you a better
person just for like a million reasons
like you're just putting yourself first
yeah i agree i think that you
need to just like you know that you did
the right thing but just like hold true
to that and there's really aside from
the fact that i guess like it sounds a
little funny like you wrote it like 25
year old divorcee or
i don't know i don't i think it's very
very chic and if you look at it through
that lens like you might be empowered i
just want to say it's giving like i
don't know
it's giving like energy and it's also
giving because it's giving very
confident like i know myself energy and
like i know that this wasn't right for
me and even though it was the most
painful
thing to do and then like we have to
undo years of legal stuff now and like a
relationship and this and that but like
i know myself and and most people don't
especially still at 25 even and so
that's what it says to me
i agree i think you sound like a
fabulous gal and like lean into it yeah
best of luck
again if any of you guys have written in
to us in the last couple weeks and we
have read it on air please we're
desperate for updates like what happened
write us an email deartoasters gmail.com
or if you're just someone in native
advice again deartoasters gmail.com
that's our show our show thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
got radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find out
some morning chess and leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
and if you made to the end of this
episode why don't you drop an emoji on
our most recent instagram of some money
in honor of daddy warbucks hopefully
that girl gets every coin coming to her
yes have an amazing day you guys will
see you tomorrow bye